un dinosaure du rock à l'olympia c'était
hier soir l'unique concert parisien de
david bowie deux mille cinq cents
privilégiés et plusieurs générations
dans la salle au libellé nous disent à
manille diawara je voulais m'excuser
mais vous avez l'air fier d'avoir ce
billet
avoir un peu je suis fier et qu'il n'a
pas de prix de billets 50 euros non
50 millions
un mythe sur l'olympe l'olympia
accueille le dandy du rock
eddy pierre jacques brel ont chanté ici
alain une salle à la réputation
légendaire qui jouait au début des
années 90 là c'est un très beau théâtre
chamas il a devancé les modes grille
mais son visage changer la face du rove
une tonne de provocation une ambiguïté
sexuelle aujourd'hui à 55 ans l'homme
aux mille et un visages semblent sereins
les hommes le siècle dernier avait un
désir dément de devenir vieux
c'était une situation immonde une idée
désormais oubliée aujourd'hui il ya un
vrai renouveau une vraie recherche
spirituelle
100 minutes de concert quelques titres
de son dernier album le 25e et la
reprise de ses plus grands succès que
dire ce fut beau oui puisque bien même
il ya de l'élégance méchant
formidablement bien
vous avez dit que le jour n'est pas 50
millions j'avais raison un spa raison
parce que c'était génial